قالت وكيله الامين العامه للامم المتحده
للشؤون الليليه السياسيه روزماري دي كارلو
قالت ان الامم المتحده ليست في وضع يمكنها
من التحقق من صحه اي ادعاءات بشان من يقف
وراء تفجير انبوبي الغاز
وحتى دي كارلو خلال جلسه لمجلس الامن
الدولي بهذا الشان دعت اليها روسيا حتى
جميع الاطراف على ضبط النفس وتجنب
التكهنات واي اتهامات من شانها تصعيد
التوتر
من جهته قلل مندوب الروسي وفي مجلس الامن
الدولي
على يقين تام ليس فقط بمن فجر خطوط انابيب
نورسريم بل ايضا كيف تم تفجيرها مشيرا الى
مقال الصحافي الامريكي سيمور هرش الذي
تعمل الولايات المتحده والنرويج بالوقوف
وراء هذه العمليه
بالنظر الى الادله المتاحه لن يوافق اي
محام على الدفاع عن زملائنا الامريكيين
ولن يكون حكم هيئه المحلفين موضع شك على
الاطلاق لكننا لسنا هنا من اجل اقامه
محاكمه في مجلس الامن كما تعلمون قدمنا
مشروع قرار بمجلس الامن الدولي يطلب من
الامين العام اجراء تحقيق دولي مستقل كان
علينا القيام بذلك لان لدينا شكوكا كبيره
فيما يتعلق بفعاليه وشفافيه وحياد
التحقيقات التي تجرى حاليا في عدد من
الدول ولا نرى رغبه من شركائنا في التعاون
في المقابل نفهم ممثل البعثه الامريكيه في
مجلس الامن الدولي جون كيلي لتهاماتيه
الروسيه واكد ان بلاده غير متورطه في
عمليه تخريب خطوط انابيب نورسريم واعتبر
كيليان روسيا تحاول صرف انتباه المجتمع
الدولي عن افعالها في اوكرانيا من خلال
توجيه اصابع الاتهام لواشنطن
اسمحوا لي ان اقول بوضوح وصراحه ان
الاتهامات بان الولايات المتحده متورطه في
هذا العمل التخريبي كاذبه تمامه لم تكن
الولايات المتحده متورطه على الاطلاق تحقق
السلطات المختصه في الدنمارك والمانيا
والسويد في هذه الحوادث بطريقه شفافه من
الواضح ان مشروع القرار الروسي يورط
الولايات المتحده ويخطئ في توصيف تصريحات
المسؤولين الامريكيين روسيا لا تسعى الى
تحقيق نزيه بل تسعى الى الحاق الضرر
بالتحقيق التجاريه ودفعها اتجاه نتيجه
محدده سلفا من اختيارها